okay so again the same thing that I
always say there's not two Arts okay so
as we come in already I reconciling my
materiality my energy that is working
through me going through my body onto
the ground vectors as we come in then I
yield so here's my angle change
my angle change
right but I'm not just trying to get out
so as as I change my angle in other
words I don't leave his body there his
body's moving with me you see
with my with my adhesions
so if that doesn't change as I come
around
his body is his body is in is in me and
I'm in his body
say you're not here trying to just leave
him there
you're in his body in his body from the
start in his body really started
okay boom here
oh this is
juji
okay okay so already reconciling my own
energy connecting to his energy and
remember on GG not yet you're not
accelerating him you have you're going
when you're doing it for real you got to
displace this leg okay do you understand
you're you're not you don't go here you
go through this link
okay
and that's going to require you again
I'm in this body that's going to require
you again to as you feel his mass that
energy too has to be internalized
okay let's go okay so continuing on
yesterday's thing right uh always look
for these wrist locks in here if people
uh
[Music]
we'll forget them and they should always
pay for touching you okay and so as I go
through my wrist locks here
you'll find them uh
you'll let's say let's say I go for the
wrist lock and he pulls his arm out now
because he's he's trying to do uh
his stuff and you know create openings
do you see that as he has to protect
himself okay you understand that so the
same thing like on the
on the ground
right and uh
let's say uh I'm doing this kind of
stuff right and he's got no choice but
to try to create space with the other
arm because I'm pinning it and he's got
no space here so as he goes to create
space well that's where I'm attacking
the wrist you see and so from that from
that wrist attack I'm still attacking
the wrist
DC as I'm going into the mount it is
much easier mount
then I'm kind of now and he has pure 100
defense you got that
Okay so
on this one we'll go slow but it's the
same thing
take the yin space
use your shoulder and push
and my hand catches
the action here
instead of stepping in to attack the leg
I step in to keep contact with the elbow
and that's where I find it
yield again in his body so his body is
with me
boom bodies with me
okay let's get there
all right so we're going to take the the
bottom half component of the of juji not
yet
okay so I have my lock in here and I
because I am attacking a leg
you've seen you you will have the throw
again what what's happening on his upper
body is just where wherever I'm touching
that's that's your IP adhesion that's
where you're in his body I do have a
lock but I'm not in the joints
I have a lock here but it's in his body
all right you see so Aikido don't attack
you could if you want you could attack
The Joint but here I just I'm using that
joint in the same way that where
wherever I'm touching as I'm in his body
do you understand okay so I'm using the
joint and then I attack the ledge
so slip attack The Joint you don't have
to push your wrist like that right it is
kind of like that because he hooked
right oh got it okay I'm in here you
might have to step up again to get the
right edema depth on the leg
notice that I kick back over the top
okay
okay so this is the front
uh inward kazushi that you're using okay
and on the front inward kazushi you'll
you'll always attack this leg
which is really this hip okay any
anywhere from
his Hara down to Mid leg is where where
you come in
so you have you have your ikyo and
that's where you're coming in here
remember it's a body attack you're not
attacking the arm
you remember say yes I remember okay so
you're coming in here
so we do uh juji nugget and the same
thing there there it is right there
right there select
uh it doesn't matter I'm on me it
doesn't matter there's the leg that's
where I come in
so just like in Nico
I don't bypass the legs you get the arm
on GG now I guess same thing
a knot just accelerating him by the arm
like on me
pretty much here
[Music]
and this takes the
technique is I'm not attacking his arm I
don't have to use my arms okay and we're
just using that principle here
so as I come around
on the first technique right again there
it is right there
stay there please
there's that triangle and that's why I
insert my triangle and let's turn this
to the camera can see okay
I don't have to I don't want to parallel
you I'm going to attack this leg
so if you pay attention to my arms on
the first technique
they don't do anything
they just stay united into my body
well the same thing is happening on this
technique
get out of your arms
as you're going
into the lock
don't pull the arm down
you're gonna take the lock off
keep the lock on and attack the leg
the only arm movement comes after for
that final Coq projection okay
so here
slip
in
don't undo the lock keep the lock and
attack the leg
then the arm movement comes on that
final folk View okay let me try it again